[موسيقى]
في اقاصي شرق الهضبه الاثيوبيه وعلى بعد
نحو 500 كيلومتر من العاصمه اديس ابابا
نجد مدينه هرر التاريخيه التي تعود
لمملكتها هرار الاسلاميه والتي استمدت جل
ثقافتها من الممالك الاسلاميه القديمه كنز
من التاريخ يعود لاكثر من الف عام
[موسيقى]
فما انهممنا لدخول مدينه هرر حتى داهمنا
سور المدينه وبواباته الحصينه الخمس حيث
يشهد هذا السور على التاريخ ويسهم في
تشكيل مشهد بديع لملامح الزمان والمكان
غير انه ما زال يكابد المتغيرات ليحتفظ
ببعض ملامحه القديمه
[موسيقى]
فسوروا مدينه هرر بني على طراز معماري
عربي واسلامي مغطيا جهاتها الاربع
لحمايتها من الغزو ويرجع تاريخ السور الى
القرن الثالث عشر الميلادي ولابواب السور
الخمسه مسميات عربيه هي باب النصر وباب
السلام وباب بدر وباب الرحمه وباب البحر
الاحمر ويربط اهل هرر الابواب الخمسه
برمزيه داله على اركان الاسلام الخمس
ما بدي اقرا طارق
ينظر مدينه هرره المسوره هي نتاج حضاره
عريقه في زمن ما قبل الاسلام ونعتز بها
كثيرا وترمز الابواب الخمسه لصور هذه
المدينه لاهم المقومات الاساسيه في
الاسلام وهي اركانه لكن تعود نشاه هذه
المدينه بعد الترابط القوي بين ابناء
العمومه لامراء هرر في منشائهم الاساسي
وهي هرل
واتفاقهم لانشاء حكومه في مدينه هرر
الحاليه
هؤلاء هم من اتحدوا واتفقوا على انشاء هذه
المدينه قبل الاسلام
واجدادنا هم اول من قبل الاسلام في شرق
افريقيا